hey everyone in cereth register nurse RN
calm and today we're going to talk about
thiazide diuretics and as always after
you watch this youtube video you can
access the free quiz that will test you
on this medication so let's get started
as we've been reviewing these
medications in this pharmacology series
we have been remembering the word nurse
because each letter of that word helps
us remember those important concepts we
need to know for exams so first we're
going to talk about the name
specifically the family name of the drug
because this tells us how the drug works
on the body and we're dealing with the
thiazide family specifically those
thiazide diuretics well thiazide tells
us that this medication works in the
early part of the distal convoluted
tubule that's found within this nephron
and what this drug is going to do it's
going to affect a co transporter that's
found within this early part of the dct
and this transporter is called the
sodium chloride co-transporter and it is
considered a cyanide sensitive
transporter so hence why this drug works
so well and what it's going to do is
it's going to prevent this transporter
from being able to do its job and just
as its name says is that this
transporter transports sodium and
chloride from the filtrate to go back
into the blood to be reabsorbed by the
body well for stopping this process of
this sodium chloride going back into the
body that means it's gonna stay in this
filtrate which eventually turns into
urine when it exits the body so if we
have sodium chloride stained in this
filtrate it's going to result in
increased sodium in the filtrate which
is going to draw water to it
because water loves sodium so more water
will stay in this filtrate will not be
reabsorbed back into the body less of it
will be and this is going to cause the
person to have increased urination
because we have more fluid in the urine
so we're getting those diuretic effects
that this drug does and this will help
slightly decrease our blood volume you
because we're
moving it now thiazide diuretics are not
as potent or as powerful as loot
diuretics like furosemide and the reason
for that is because each type of
diuretic that you have is going to
affect different structures within this
nephron which is going to alter how
sodium is reabsorbed back into the body
because if we keep it in the filtrate
that means water is going to stay there
and that's going to help provide that
diuresis effect so for example loop
diuretics we learn work in the loop of
Henle and specifically this thick
ascending line' and this thick ascending
limb is responsible for about 25 percent
of sodium reabsorption so we throw on a
lube diuretic we're not going to be
reabsorbing all that said he was going
to stay in the filtrate that's a high
percentage of sodium so it's going to
have a stronger effect by keeping water
in it compared to this distal convoluted
tubule where it only accounts for about
five to seven percent of sodium
reabsorption so you can see the
percentage differences and while loop
diuretics are a lot more effective than
a thiazide diuretic but the thiazide
diuretic does provide a nice diuresis
effect not as strong as a loop diuretic
and another thing about thiazide is that
they're less effective in patients who
have a compromised GFR a go merrill ER
filtration rate meaning that this
glomerulus of this nephron is not very
effective in filtering the blood and
with loop diuretics they are good in
patients who have this compromised GFR
like they have renal failure let's say
you have a patient with renal failure
who has fluid volume overload well we
can give them a loop diuretic and that
can help remove that fluid but with a
thigh we wouldn't want to do that
because their GFR is compromised in some
examples of thiazide diuretics are like
hydrochlorothiazide in DAP amide clora
thiazide Mottola zone and chlorothalonil
unfortunately we can't go by their
ending like with some of the other drugs
generic names but some do in in thiazide
now let's talk about how these thiazide
diuretics work on this nephron to cause
diuresis but to do that let's review the
basic anatomy and physiology of this
nephron here's an illustration of a
nephron if we took a nephron and
stretched it out it would look something
similar to this also you can see how the
nephron sets within the kidneys and
these structures work within the kidneys
to allow them to function and without
them working properly the kidney fails
to do its job and there are millions of
these little nephron structures within
each kidney and they function to filter
the blood and manage the amount of water
ions and waste in the blood and either
it's going to cause some ions and water
to be reabsorbed back into the blood so
you can use them or it's going to make
it where the ions and specifically waste
and water will stay in the filtrate so
it'll be excreted as urine so these
little structures are always tweaking
this filtrate that's created by the
glomerulus until it's where your body
needs it to be and if it's not you
excrete it as urine and the nephron is
divided into several parts and each part
has its own unique role for tweaking
this filtrate which is why certain
diuretics work on certain areas of the
nephron and the parts of the nephron
include the afferent and efferent
arteriole the afferent arteriole
delivers blood via the renal artery to
the nephron so it can be filtered the
afferent arteriole takes blood away from
the nephron after it has been filtered
so when the nephron receives blood
through the afferent arteriole it's
going to go through the glomerulus and
this is going to filter the blood and
create the filtrate which will
eventually exit the body as urine and
the filtrate is going to contain
ions which are like electrolytes water
and waste and it's gonna drip down into
Bowman's capsule which will collect the
filtrate as it drips down from that
mara less then the filtrate is going to
start its journey of being tweaked and
by the other parts of the nephron to the
point where the body is satisfied with
it and what it doesn't want it's going
to be excreted as urine so the first
stop is the proximal convoluted tubule
and this area is going to reabsorb water
ions etc and the parts that we've talked
about up to this point hang out in the
renal cortex of the kidney and this
provides like an isotonic environment
where the sodium concentration is equal
in the inside hence the nephron and that
filtrate compared to the outside however
as this filtrate starts progressing
going down into the loop of Henle it's
going to enter into a hypertonic
environment because it's in the renal
medulla and this is very necessary for
water re-absorption by that descending
limb of the loop of Henle and the
collecting duct so once it leaves the
proximal convoluted tubule it's going to
go down into the loop of Henle and then
loop of Henle has the descending and a
sending limb so it's tweaked there as
well and remember I talked about how
that thick ascending limb is responsible
for about 25% of sodium reabsorption so
the filtrate is going to go up and again
it's going to enter back into the
isotonic environment and it's going to
go into the distal convoluted tubule and
this is the structure that we care about
for this lecture for the thiazide
because this is where the thiazide
diuretics works specifically in that
early part and some functions of this
distal convoluted tubule is to of course
reabsorb sodium and chloride but it also
plays a role in reabsorbing calcium and
i want you to remember that because one
of the side effects of thiazide
diuretics is that it can increase
calcium levels and also it plays a role
with secretion of potassium into the
filtrate then it leaves the DCT and it's
making its journey to the collecting
ducts and this is the last part of the
nephron where the filtrate is finally
tweaked ions and water will be it
reabsorbed and the last part of the
collecting duct is found in that renal
medulla and this will play one last role
with that water reabsorption then it
will exit the body through the renal
pelvis and you will have urine which
will go to the ureters and be urinated
out now let's go a little bit more in
depth to how these thighs I diuretics
work in this distal convoluted tubule
and tie it in with why we're gonna see
these certain electrolyte imbalances for
these patients and these are some
important concepts you want to remember
for your exams because it'll tie in with
your nursing interventions and your
patient teaching so we've already
established that the distal convoluted
tubule is going to play a role in us
reabsorbing sodium and chloride and
calcium and the secretion of potassium
ions as well into the back into this
filtrate so the distal convoluted tubule
when we throw a thiazide and it's going
to affect this code transport the sodium
chloride co-transporter it's going to
prevent it from allowing these sodium
and chloride ions from leaving the
filtrate and going back into the blood
and hanging out in the blood and keeping
those levels nice and stable so because
we're not going to be receiving that
sodium we are going to potentially lower
the sodium levels in the blood leading
to hyponatremia so that's one
electrolyte imbalance you want to watch
out for now because we're inhibiting
this co-transporter it's going to alter
how these other channels and
transporters can work within this distal
convoluted tubule to deal with other
ions to be reabsorbed and one ion
reabsorption that's going to be affected
will be calcium because it is affected
by a particular channel known as the t
RP v v channel and because we inhibit
this sodium chloride coat transporter
it's actually going to inhale
how this channel works so it helps the
body reabsorb calcium back into the
blood well for enhancing how this
channel works we're going to be
reabsorbing more calcium in the blood
which can lead to hypercalcemia
increasing our calcium levels in the
blood a normal calcium level is about
eight point five to ten point five
milligrams per deciliter
now this can actually be beneficial and
we're going into a little bit for what
this drug is used for but patients who
have recurrent renal stones that are
composed of calcium can actually benefit
from this because if we are increasing
calcium reabsorption from the filtrate
to go back into the blood that's leaving
less calcium and that filtrate which
leaves less calcium that can help create
a renal stone also patients who have low
calcium levels we can possibly throw in
a thiazide to help increase the
reabsorption of calcium in the blood
which can hopefully help increase their
bone density so it can be beneficial in
some instances but as a nurse you want
to watch that calcium level also
thiazide diuretics can cause hypokalemia
and that was similar to our loop
diuretics they also can lower the
potassium level so they share that and
why is that same like with loop
diuretics as this filtrate travels
through this distal convoluted tubule
here we in the early part we prevented
that sodium from being reabsorbed so
more is hanging out in the filtrate
well it's journeying down through rest
of this to be oh well it's high in
sodium and these channels are influenced
by aldosterone and we've learned that
aldosterone causes the body to keep
water and sodium in exchange for
potassium so if we have a lot of sodium
in the filtrate traveling down through
these aldosterone influence channels
that's really going to cause the body to
secrete potassium into that filtrate
which is going to lower our potassium
levels and also going with that
potassium
hydrogen ions so we can lower our
potassium levels in normal potassium
levels about 3.5 to 5 milli equivalents
per liter and the patient could possibly
experience metabolic alkalosis due to
the loss of those hydrogen ions so
remember that and patients may have to
take potassium supplements you'll want
to be watching that potassium level for
sure especially if they're on other
medications which we'll talk about here
in a moment and educate them about foods
that are rich in potassium and they want
to definitely keep those in their diet
those are diuretics can also alter the
blood sugar and this is important to
know for your patients who are diabetic
thiazide diuretics can increase the
blood glucose level the reason for why
they do that is not truly understood but
we want to educate our patients to
monitor their glucose glucose level
closely because their insulin or their
oral diabetic medications may have to be
tweaked based on if they're getting this
hyperglycemia and thiazide diuretics can
increase uric acid levels which can lead
to gout attacks and the reason for this
is that these drugs alter how the
proximal convoluted tubule deals with
your ate and it actually increases how
urate is reabsorbed which can increase
your gas levels and lead to gaol attacks
so you may need to monitor those uric
acid levels and high uric acid levels
for a male tends to be anywhere anything
greater than seven and four females
greater than six so if you see a uric
acid level of 15 that is not good that
means that they have high uric acid
levels so what if eyes I diabetics use
four which is the second part of our
word of nurse well they can be used to
treat hypertension high blood pressure
and they're usually about the first line
for helping a patient treat their high
blood pressure and what it's going to do
it's going to decrease that sodium and
water out of the blood which can help
lower the blood pressure in addition
they can be ordered for patients who
have heart failure this is where the
heart is weak to pump blood it becomes
overwhelmed and blood starts backing up
into the lungs and to the body and the
patient is really just miserable so what
these medications can do is they can be
prescribed a lot of times with ACE
inhibitors and we talked all about ACE
inhibitors and this can help actually
increase the function of the heart and
help the patient feel better also as
we've talked about thiazide diuretics
can be used in the treatment of renal
calculi which are those renal stones
that are composed of calcium now let's
wrap up this review and let's talk about
nursing responsibilities the side
effects and education pieces for the
patient who may be taking a thigh-high
diuretic so whenever you have a patient
taking a thiazide you really want to be
watching out for signs and symptoms of
dehydration because we're increasing
your their urination and how much fluid
is being removed from their blood
volumes so some things as a nurse you
can watch out for is you can look at
their vital signs how is their blood
pressure if it's hypotensive low that's
the salts less than 90 that probably
means that we've removed a little bit
too much fluid volume from their blood
also the heart rate will be increased as
well we're tachycardic from where the
heart's trying to compensate for that
loss of fluid volume then we can also
look at their eyes and O's you want to
make sure you are strictly measuring
that and the patient can help you with
that they're alert and oriented and
whenever they go to use the bathroom to
urinate you definitely want to make sure
you were measuring that because you want
to look to see how much they're taking
in versus how much they're putting out
they're really not putting out anything
at all the renal function could be
compromised
so we want to make sure that we are
digressing them but not too much and we
can look at their daily weights where we
weigh them every day at the same time
using the same scale this tells us their
fluids status and really tells us how
effective this medication is working
because if they're gaining weight
instead of losing weight we made
not very effective with this diuretic
they may need something else anyone to
teach the patient to weigh themselves a
lot of patients with heart failure may
be on these medications and we want to
teach them to weigh themselves every day
and to write it down to keep track
because if they've gained more than like
three pounds in one day that could mean
that they're retaining fluid and they
may be having heart failure exacerbation
and will need to go to their doctor to
get treatment also as a nurse
we want to monitor their labs because as
we've learned these drugs cause
electrolyte imbalances so the physician
will order the labs we will get those
results and we will look at them you
always want to look into results
especially before you give their
medications because electrolyte
imbalances can induce like toxicity of
other drugs so we've learned that the I
sides cause a lot of hypo a lot of hyper
conditions so let's talk about the hypo
we know that it can lower the calcium
and potassium levels causing hypokalemia
and if your patient is on digoxin and
their potassium level goes too low it
can increase the risk of digoxin
toxicity so always look at that
potassium level and be educating your
patient to be consuming foods that are
rich in potassium like bananas avocados
strawberries potatoes etc because that
will help keep that level high in a
normal digital I just want to throw this
in there is about 0.5 to 2 nanograms per
milliliter the other hypo condition you
can cost is hyponatremia where that
sodium level is too low and that was
another thing that lube diuretics did as
well it can lower it too low so if you
had a patient who's taking lithium
that's not good because when sodium
levels drop if a patient's taking
lithium it can increase the risk of
lithium toxicity so a normal lithium
level is about 0.5 to 1.2 millimoles per
liter so remember these two drugs if we
go into these hypo conditions either
hyponatremia or hypokalemia with those
it can cause toxicity those are some
important concepts
no exams love to ask about the hyper
conditions that these drugs can cause
our hyper hyper Cal C Mia the high
calcium level hyperuricemia the high
uric acid level and hyperglycemia again
teach your diabetic patients to monitor
their blood glucose really closely while
taking a thigh and some other little
miscellaneous things you want to
remember is that whenever you give a
patient any type of diuretic they can
get up and use the bathroom on their own
you need to make sure they have easy
access to it because you don't want them
to fall and get hurt and avoid giving
doses of diuretics at night because we
want our patients to sleep at night we
don't want them up using the bathroom
all the time so make sure you're not
doing that and orthostatic hypotension
this is where the when the patients
maybe they've been sitting or lying down
they get up they can fall they become
dizzy you want to teach them to change
position slowly because we're altering
the fluid status in their body and as a
nurse you want to make sure that this
medication is being effective is it
doing its job how do their lungs sound
is their blood pressure coming down
maybe they're getting this drug for
hypertension how is their weights are
they gaining weight or losing weight so
we play a huge role with that as well
okay so that wraps up this review over
thighs I diuretics thank you so much for
watching don't forget to take the free
quiz and to subscribe to our channel for
more videos